oh mein gott oh mein gott oh mein gott
herz bekommt so eine neue leute ich
trete heute gegen meinen sitznachbarn
der auch sebastian heißt wir
wahrscheinlich weiß an und zwar in eine
aufgabe die für dich quasi unmöglich ist
denn das geht heute darum nicht zu
zucken genau dass wir jetzt ein video
sehen dieses video wird sehr extrem sein
und es geht dabei darum nicht zu zucken
das heißt man darf nicht werkstoffen
bildschirm man darf keine reaktion wie
so oder so was zeigen
und ja eigentlich noch einfach darum
dass ich boxe ich euch was da passiert
das war ich richtig spannend sagt er ist
tot ja das war eine reaktion
das war eine reaktion wie kann ich so
was nicht jucken gefäße auto oder ja wie
kann ich so was nicht
sechs jahre so scheiß egal ob du nicht
überleben ich sehe jeden tag so viel
scheiße das ist also ich bin einfach
nicht mehr die chance besitzt den
unglaublich netter junge ja ok aber ich
muss sagen ich habe mich schon
eigentlich wenn ich bin im modus
entweder tolle rhythmus aber du bist das
ganze mal autofahren ohne witz ich bin
einmal bei dem auto mitgefahren na ja da
ist mir nicht aufgefallen
aber kann es sein dass du so durch die
gegend oder brennende oma und den
festplatz spiele gehen richtig und
weiter gerade mal den profi-kader okay
das finde ich auch glas das finde ich
auch zu krass alter da habe ich richtig
schließen weil ich fahre nämlich kein
motorrad und jedes mal wenn ich denke
ich fahre motorrad wird mir sowas
passieren wie auch denkst du dass du
motorradfahrer ist ziemlich offen was
ist hier eigentlich auch das kommt noch
dazu wenn das auto fertig sind ist die
beiden omas egal sondern wir jetzt also
den steuer und die rechte an kmu
das geht über in göttlicher mein gott
als ob ich genau dem werk gestoppt hat
berühren die sich cody müssen sich ein
kombinates auto ist es müssen ja aus der
bahn ist nichts was passiert da ein
kontakt oder ja herzattacke
naja ich hab schon ein anderes geräusch
gehört wartete geschickt oder
[Musik]
die zwei jungs ja auch nicht nur okay
weil es einfach gar nicht erst aktiv
wenn du wieder gefragt sagt ja gut das
kennen wir sind dort auch also da wo ich
herkomme bricht auch mal jedenfalls
hatten bürger also der bürgermeister
verein aktiv zu werden wenn die brände
oma ins loch
oh mein gott oh mein gott oh mein gott
jaedicke hast du gesehen wie knapp das
war richtig runter nach junge alter des
excel der stelle richtig cool erschießt
einen kühlschrank alles klar hatte ich
das jetzt geschickt ja irgendwie schon
man duckt sich automatisch weg finde ich
glaube dass so ein rallye ging heute
gleich von der wurst um die exko das
kann man eigentlich sagen dass ich und
du hast für tabak für selbst ja also es
also bald also weiß eigentlich ist das
jetzt ein richtig schönes auto mit
heckantrieb und jetzt kommts mal gucken
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
wie knapp das gehäuse
das war okay muss konstant machen
[Musik]
ist ja so ein loch ist komplett jetzt
immer voll da ist ja gar nicht passiert
weil man sagen ja das ist richtig top es
jetzt haben hier schon ab und weckte
ziehen wird dass wir da hatte ich dachte
ich sag dir das wird hart um alter vater
stell dir ganz kurz vor was wäre
passiert wenn er zehn zentimeter weiter
vorne gewesen wäre
nein neidiger das board krass
[Musik]
jung mein gott ich trete auf den kopf g
bitte was für ein fettes fähig junge
zürich alter mein gott oh mein gott oh
mein gott mein er landet was leider dass
mehr junge aus der ego-perspektive schau
leben alter walter alter fahrer muss los
leute was man dazu sagen da waren
definitiv krankes system dabei auf die
meisten verschickt hat war diese szene
mit dem mobilen aber was ich habe immer
noch am meisten stört mich wenn ich
jetzt so reingehen wenn wir dann sehen
und dann war's das halt einfach passt
auf jeden fall auch wenn ihr unterwegs
sollte beides auf der straße also mit
heckantrieb mit heckantrieb das ganze